welcome back to las vegas now you know
what makes a refreshing summer treat
even better
when the treats are vegas born local
company the joy pop co
is here to tell us how we can help them
celebrate their second anniversary with
some very unique popsicles i must say
okay welcome
our owners here you guys i must have i
must share this story with you
i was at a local event the other day and
i saw the joy pop cart
there and i ran across the football
field oh my god i'm so excited to
finally try them and i have the mango
dragon fruit and it was so good
yeah that's really so good my favorite
oh my gosh okay so let's talk flavors
okay
what are we what are we getting into for
the summer so
for the summer we have our creamy and
fruity flavors but
what we're really excited about this
week is with our birthday cake pop
gosh made with vanilla cake and
buttercream on top with sprinkles
dipped in our vanilla cream base okay
i'm sorry i'm
actually trying it right now and it's
delicious oh my gosh they're so
flavorful
so tell us more about this pop in
particular it is limited time obviously
how long can people enjoy it and what
are they going to get out of it
yeah so a single single make so
we it should be around for a few weeks
while we celebrate our birthday
this week um and it's really meant to
create
or recreate that feeling of like you
know birthday cake and ice cream and
that
that bite all together when you get the
perfect bite so that's really what the
pop's all about you guys nailed it
because i i feel like i'm literally
eating birthday cake right now
so what goes into making your popsicles
how do you guys separate yourselves from
just
you know regular popsicles that's a good
question
yeah um so we do source a lot of
ingredients locally we've done coffee
pops with local roasters
we use real simple ingredients you know
no dyes no artificial preservatives
made from scratch everything we make our
shortcake our cake our cookies in-house
oh my gosh it's so delicious okay and
tell everybody what the giveaway is that
we can
join you guys with this week as well so
we are partnering with some of our local
retailers
wonderful businesses around town that
have all pitched in some gift cards for
the community
and we're just going to do one big
birthday giveaway okay birthday giveaway
popsicles you can't get any more festive
than that and where can people find you
guys and more information
you can find us on our website but you
can also find us around town at
different farmers markets and events
look for the cart yep the card will be
there and
you can always order online as well all
right well thank you guys so much for
joining us congrats on to a local
company we love to see that jc i will
send it over to you
and send me a popsicle too oh maybe oh
come on